نحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد بقدر ما يتطلبه
الامر سيستمر دعم واشنطن لاوكرانيا في
معركتها ضد روسيا هذا التعهد لرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن تبعه كشفه بان تتضمن
حزمه المساعده الجديده اسلحه وذخائر
وانظمه الدفاع جوي بالاضافه الى المزيد من
صواريخ مارس الامريكيه وهو تاكيد لما
نقلته رويتر سابقا عن مسؤولين امريكيين
بان الولايات المتحده تعد او تعد لحزمه
مساعدات عسكريه بقيمه 2.2 مليار دولار
لاوكرانيا من المتوقع ان تشمل صواريخ
طويله المدى لاول مره من جهته الغرب ثابت
على مبدا تقديم الدعم اوكرانيا في وجه
روسيا لدرجه انه وبعد تردد طويل قررت
تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات قتاليه ثقيله ما
فتح شهيه اكياف على ما يبدو للمطالبه
باسلحه هجوميه كطائرات المقاتله الغواصات
هذا بخلاف الدبابات الالمانيه
وعربات الجنود المدرعه مارتن نناقش هذا
الجزء مع ضيوفنا من الكويت ايضا شهيده
دبلوماسيه والاوكراني اهلا بك من جنيف
الدكتور حسني عبيدي الحلقه الدوليه بجامعه
ومحاضر في معهد العلوم السياسيه في باريس
اهلا بكم وظيف الكريمين واسم حالي ان ابدا
من الكويت معك سيد شهيده في الواقع هذا
العام الذي شهد وعشنا من خلاله وتبعنا
تفاصيل هذه الحرب بداناه بدعم الغرب
لاكياس بانظمه دفاعيه ختمناه بدعم الغرب
لاكياس باسلحه متطوره ومطالبه
زيلنسكي بالافته عشر وباسلحه طويله المدى
هذا الدعم هل حمى كياف او هذا الدعم قد
ياخذنا الى مرحله ومستوى جديد من التسلح
اعتقد ان الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا هو
سيساعد في انهاء هذه الحرب في اقرب وقت
لان الدفاع هو ليس تصعيد الدفاع عن النفس
طبقا للبطاقه الامم المتحده حقنا في
لاوكرانيا ونحن نصير الى حقنا الكامل طبقا
للقوانين الدوليه بالنسبه
مثلا اذا نتحدث عن اسلحه طويله المدى فيما
ستفيد كيف
اولا
تدمير اللوجيات الروسيه
لتدبيره هجوم اوسع والان هذا الهجوم مستمر
في اوكرانيا في باخموت وطبعا نحن نحتاج
لهذه الاسلحه حتى يكون كما يسمى طويله
لتحرير كذلك
ونحن لا نتاجر باراضينا ولا نتاجر بالشعب
الذي يعيش في داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه ولو
كانت محتله مؤقته من طرف روسيا وطبعا
بتحريرها بشكل كامل دكتور حسني ما رايك هل
هذه النوعيه وهذه الطريقه المستمره في
تصليح كيف مناسبه لهذه المرحله يمكن كما
يقول ضيفي ان تحمي اكياف وان لا تاخذنا
للصراع قد يكون اكبر ومتعدد الاطراف
يعني مساعدتك امر مشروع وللحلف الاطلسي
والدول الغربيه لديها الحق في النهايه
الدفع بقوات عسكريه وبدعم عسكري
نوعي مختلف عن
الدعم السابق لكن
الدعم العسكري لنقول التسليح بلا نهايه لا
محدود يحمل اخطار كبيره هو انه قبل كل شيء
سيلغي اي احتماليه
للسلام ثم كذلك انا اعتقد بان ميزان القوى
حتى وان استطاعت اوكرانيا الى حد الساعه
ان تدافع عن نفسها وان تصمد امام الغزو
الروسي الا ان في النهايه
يعني يتم الا تمديد اماده هذه الحرب اكثر
دمار لاوكرانيا وكذلك اعتقد حرب استنزاف
لا يمكن لروسيا الحاليه بقياده بوتين ان
تتراجعنا فانا اعتقد ان التسليح فقط من
اجل التسليح والقول بان التسليح سيؤدي الى
حل سياسي صعب جدا الان لا فعلا ان يكون
هناك تزامن بين هذا التسليح مره اخرى
المشروع لاوكرانيا وفي نفس الوقت ان العمل
على دينامية سياسيه دبلوماسيه من قبل جميع
الدول من قبل المجتمع الدولي وليس فقط
الغرب مقابل روسيا ما رايك سيد سعيد هذا
تصليح المستمر قد ياخذ هذه الاطراف الى
صراعات اكبر واثقل خاصه وان هذا التصليح
كان له رد روسي روسيا اليوم انسحبت من نيو
ستارت وهي تتحدث عن امكانيه تطوير اسلحتها
على ما تعول الكياف في هذا الموضوع
الان روسيا تستعمل كل وسائل متاحه لديها
هي لا طبخ الفئه الصليبه الحربيه ضد
اوكرانيا من الناحيه
الاسلحه وكذلك
الهجوم السبرالي والمعلوماتي والى اخرها
وطبعا نحن انفسنا وافضل طريقه لمنع الحدوث
الحرب العالميه الثانيه الثالثه عفوا هو
اصرار النطاق الامم المتوحده واخراج روسيا
الى حدودها المعترف بها دوليا بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا هذه الاسلحه يعني نحن لا نريد
استعمال لها لغاز روسيا نحن نريد لتحرير
الاراضي الاوكرانيه والسلام يجب ان يكون
مبني على على اساس ذلك لانه تقريبا هو
كذلك مثال غير صحيح لايديكتور اخر في
العالم الذي حتى لو كان عنده اسلحه نوويه
او ربما لم يكن لدي الان وهو سيحصل عليها
ويريد ان يغير الموازين القوى ويحول مشاكل
او ليس مشاكل يعني نزعات بطريقه الاسلحه
ويجب ان يكون ان يعرف ان اهل الرد العالمي
وامم المتحده سيكون حاسم ولا نسمح بتغيير
وبخرق الدولي المتحده اذا استطيح اوكرانيا
هو افضل طريقه لمنع الحرب العالميه
الثالثه
دكتور حسني هذه الحرب في سباق التسلح
العالمي خاصه وان هناك دراسات تتحدث عن
ارتفاع نسبه هذا التسليح اولا تتحدث مثلا
عن السويد التي رفعت في عدد جنودها
المحترفين تتحدث عن اليابان التي بدات
بتنصيب
صواريخ تفوق سرعه الصوت على الجزر
الحدوديه داخل الاوروبي كذلك يسارع في
تصليح نفسه وتسليح اوكرانيا فيما بعد فهذا
الاطار
اين سياخذنا
يعني سؤالك مهم لان المانيا يعني لاول مره
منذ نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه تم
زياده الانفاق العسكري باكثر من خمسين
بالمئه وهذا لم يحدث يعني سابقا وتيره
الانتاج الحربي في اوروبا يعني اصبحت
عاجزه على مواكبه الانفاق التسليح الانفاق
داخل اوكرانيا لان بعض الدول الاوروبيه
اصبحت غني ليست لديها ما يكفي اصلا من
عتاد حربي وبالتالي تقريبا المصانع تشتغل
24 ساعه 24 ساعه قبل كل شيء للدفع بهذا
الانتاج لمساعده اوكرانيا ثم كذلك اصبحت
انتاجوا حربي هو الاولويه هذه نقطه لديها
بعض العديد من المخاوف اولا اوروبا كما
تعلمين بلد رفاها الاقتصادي على قضيه
الاجتماع الدوله الاجتماعيه على قضيه
التربيه والتعليم الان من المؤكد ان هذا
الانفاق الكبير جدا
وفاقم من التضخم الذي هو مرتفع وبالتالي
يؤدي بعض بعض الهزات الاقتصاديه
الاجتماعيه التي نرى بعض الارهاساتها في
العديد من الدول الاوروبيه ذكرت يعني هناك
كذلك الصين يعني الصين متخوف لان تقول بان
ربما اليوم يعني ما وقع مع الغرب مع
اوكرانيا بدات كذلك في التسليح لانها لا
تريد ان يكون هناك نقاش جديد حول تايوان
حول تايوان اعتقد ان هذا السباق نحو
التسلح يعني خروج او تعليق اتفاقيه نيو
ستارت كذلك تعتبر نكسه كبيره بالنسبه لعدم
التسلح ففعلا الحرب الاوكرانيه هي اعتقد
النزاع الوحيد في العالم الذي نتائجه
واعتقد كذلك يعني تداعياته
مسه كل القطاعات وكل الدول العالم ما رايك
سيد سعيد ضيف يقول بان اول سباق التسلح
ستكون له مخاطر عديده ويقول ثانيا بان
تسليح اوكرانيا بهذه الطريقه دون اعتماد
حلول موازيه على المستوى السياسي
الدبلوماسي لن يفيد لاكياف ولن يفيد هذه
الحرب ولن ينهي هذه الازمه
اي نعم كذلك انا متفقه
ضيفكم بالنسبه لي ان التصليح الان في
العالم هو موجود غير مسبوق هو جدي في كثير
من الاماكن خاصه اريد ان اذكر هنا كذلك
كوريا الشماليه وهناك في المنطقه هناك بعض
التقلق في في اسيا رغم ان يعني الحرب
موجوده في داخل اوروبا في اوكرانيا وكذلك
اريد ان اذكر ايران الذي قد قد يطمح او
يريد ان يطمع الى للحصول على الاسلحه
النوويه والان يتحالف مع روسيا الطائرات
المسيره الاستعمالها في الحرب في اوكرانيا
ويجب يعني يجب ان ندقق بان حل داخل
اوكرانيا يعني حل دبلوماسي هو يجب ان يكون
على اساس احترام لمثاق الامم المتحده لانه
هذا النموذج لدول كايران او كاكولا
الشماليه دول اخرى التي قد تريد ان تحل
مشاكلها او ليس مشاكلها نزاعاتها مجمده
بال وطبعا
وخاصه عن طريق الغزو لبلد مجاور كما حصل
بين صدام حسين والكويت وبذلك يجب ان نصير
القانون الدولي ويجب ان لا نتفاوض في
امكانيه في التناظر ان بسبب فقط ان روسيا
عندها قوه كبيره وقوه نوويه دكتور
حصيله سنه كامله هل فشل الغرب هل فشلت
اوروبا هل فشلت واشنطن من طرح مخرج لهذه
الازمه ام ان هذه التطورات قد تفيد اي طرف
من هذين الطرفين ربما حضرتك كيف تقرا ذلك
[موسيقى]
كبيره وان تكون الاولويه الوحيده هي
اولويات الدفاع او لنقول القوه العسكريه
في النهايه
سواء مسارات الاتحاد الاوروبي او مسارات
المتحده يعني مره اخرى نرى استقطاب
الامريكيه ليس بالضروره ان يكون هو
المقاربه الاحسن
شكرا على المشاركه وكل ما تفضلتم به من
جنيف الدكتور حسني العبيدي والساده
العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه جنيف ومحاضر في
معهد العلوم السياسيه في باريس ومن الكويت
ايضا سعيده الدبلوماسي الاوكراني شكرا
لكما
سنبقى دائما في نفس هذا الاطار ولكن في
نقاش ثالث والعنوان
بعد عام من الحرب على اوكرانيا هل نجحت
العقوبات الغربيه بالحد من قدره موسكو على
مواصله الهجوم
[موسيقى]